good morning believe nation today's
message is think big over to you alico
dangote to be an entrepreneur and also
to be a visionary person you have to
actually be very very bold you have to
be ready to take calculated risk not
just any risk you have to take a
calculated risk I have to think big if
you think small you always have been
smalley life I really like today's
message because most entrepreneurs don't
think big enough you're constraining
yourself you think likely as big as your
parents think or as big as your friends
think because you're part of your
environment I don't think big enough I
feel like I need to think even bigger to
have a greater impact on the world and
the reason why I created the nth special
series and the top 10 series is is
selfish it was for me to try to get me
into greater thinking surround myself
with greatness so that i can think
bigger and do bigger and better things
and so what I encourage you today is to
think about where you could potentially
go I want you to think bigger typically
what we tend to do we have an idea we
may get really excited by it and then
immediately we think about constraints
we think about why it's not going to
work out we think about all the problems
that are going to happen along the path
just for today I want you to think about
a world with no constraints I want you
to think about where you could go if you
weren't limited by your beliefs or by
resources or by education or by whatever
excuse you're telling yourself just for
today think about how far you could go
and then start mapping a plan to
actually get there because it's possible
so think bigger today guys believe so my
question is a for you today is what is
your big dream I'm really curious leave
it in the comments below and I'm going
to check it out thank you so much for
watching continue to believe have an
amazing day and I'll see you again
tomorrow morning for another shot events
presa I did not break the toys I did not
break the toys for spider-man